[Applaudissements]
pour mes 40 ans j'ai reçu comme cadeau
d'anniversaire un citronnier plus
particulièrement un line de tahiti alors
je sais pas si vous savez que c'est une
blague de tahiti c'est la grume avec
lequel on fait les ti punch et les
mojitos c'est plus clair quand on prend
l'exemple c'est toujours plus clair cet
agrume ça a été un peu comme un début
d'une passion
quelques années plus tard 2012
en 2012 il s'est produit dans ma vie
professionnelle comme une sortie de
route
sortie de route qui a posé un problème
et qui m'a fait me rendre compte que la
route sur laquelle j'étais m'amener à
l'épuisement je me suis interrogé
j'étais coach en entreprise
j'avais créé mon entreprise depuis
quatre ans alors c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient de la charge il y avait de la
charge professionnelle il y avait de la
cherche à me diane 80 avoir créé sa
boîte est vrai que savez vous avez été
conséquents mais néanmoins je me disais
mais qu'est ce qui fait que je me suis
épuisé
je me suis reposé j'ai levé le pied et
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec un
ami les coaches et avec qui j'ai regardé
la notion d'énergie et là il m'a parlé
du flou alors le flou dans la vie
professionnelle
c'est un état interne qui fait qu'à un
moment donné je vais être au maximum de
mes capacités pour réussir le maximum de
challenge et moi qui pensais être dans
le flou je faisais un métier que j'aime
et le métier du développement des
managers de vendée qui je me suis rendu
compte qu'il me manquait une dimension
or le flou pour vous l'expliquer si je
vous donne une image à prendre l'image
du ski je m'apprête à faire une piste
noire très technique très difficile
la neige est plutôt bonne un peu poudre
est un peu d'âme et les personnes sur la
piste grand soleil
je suis au maximum de ma forme je suis
au maximum de mes capacités et là je
m'élance et là je sens le plus
dire qu'ils mentent je sens l'adrénaline
l'énergie je ne pense plus à rien que la
technicité le plaisir et l'instant
présent ça c'est le flou alors moi qui
pensais être dans le flou je me suis
rendu compte qu'il me manquait un
élément cet élément c'était le retour à
la terre le retour aux gestes le retour
au fait que dans ma vie professionnelle
il fallait que je puisse moi de l'est il
fallait que je puisse créer il fallait
que je puisse créer de l'esthétique et
là je me suis dit mais je sais ce qui me
font il faut que je cultive désagréments
alors entre temps dans les cas dernières
années j'étais passé de 1 agrumes à 3,4
à grenoble avait un mandarinier
clémentiniers et depuis c'est devenu une
passion
alors aujourd'hui j'ai à peu près 70
agrumes je suis toujours coach en
entreprise
j'ai soixante dix agrumes enfin prendre
la place si vous écoutez mon épouse et
trouve ça prend beaucoup de place mais
comme toute passion la passion ça prend
toujours de la place j'ai appris à les
cultiver parce que je n'étais pas
cultivateurs d'agrumes au départ mais le
plus intéressant c'est qu'en fait en
même temps que j'ai appris le geste de
cultiver les agrumes les agrumes mans a
pris sur ma propre façon de cultiver ma
vie et donc c'est ce que j'ai envie de
vous partager ce soir c'est les six
grandes leçons de sagesse qui viennent
de la culture des agrumes eu des gestes
donc nous allons regarder si geste de la
culture des agrumes le premier c'est
fondamental c'est le terreau quand on
cultive des agrumes en pot moi je les
cultive du blé toulouse je les ai en pot
mais le terreau est important le terreau
c'est là où la plante elle va faire ses
racines
c'est là où la plante elle va aller
chercher son nrj sono c'est ce qui va
lui permettre par son ancrage racinaire
de se développer d'autres le terreau
c'est fondamental il faut qu'il soit
porteur mais il peut être aussi des fois
un peu étouffant s'il est trop lourd
l'agrume a besoin d'un terreau plutôt de
reina et puis des fois il peut être
carrément nuisibles nippon foisonner
alors si on regarde du coup le terreau
pour nous ça veut dire quoi le terreau
c'est là où nous sommes c'est ma famille
c'est mon environnement propre proches
c'est mon entreprise c'est là où j'ai
choisi de vivre ma vie il n'y a pas de
bon de bombes et heroes pourrait dire
bon ben on sait qu'il est plus ou moins
adaptés moi si je prends un exemple j'ai
travaillé pendant dix ans dans une
entreprise américaine comme jeune
ingénieur et puis j'ai passé manager et
c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai fait des beaux
fruits je suis passé manager j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir eu une carrière sympa
mais à 30 ans je me rendais compte que
ce terreau s'était pas celui qui allait
être le plus porteur pour la suite de ma
carrière je me suis rendu compte que si
je voulais continuer à avoir des fruits
c'était pas celui-là qu'il fallait que
je continue à voir donc le terreau pour
chacun d'entre nous ça se ressent ça ce
test est à nous de nous dire mais tient
ce terreau est ce qui me va bien est ce
qui me va toujours comment je peux
l'enrichir ça c'est le premier geste
deuxième geste
c'est un geste que quand nos cultivant
des agrumes nous répétons régulièrement
arrosé fertiliser mettre de l'eau mettre
de l'engrais et là c'est un geste que
nous faisons régulièrement sans me
soucier de savoir si je vais récolter
demain je suis dans le geste d'alimenter
replante alors pour nous dire
effectivement ça peut renvoyer à quoi
certainement l'alimentation mais j'avais
envie de vous de vous éclairer sur deux
sujets qui me semble important
le premier c'est les relations salaire
en tant qu'êtres humains nous sommes des
êtres de relation et nous nous
nourrissons de nos relations
c'est important se nourrir des relations
tout autant que nourrir des relations
avec les gens et qui nous sommes et en
tant que cadre humain c'est vraiment
important de se dire est-ce que je
prends du temps pour ça pour rencontrer
des gens pour passer du temps avec eux
pour échanger et l'autre élément en
termes de fertilisation
c'est tout ce qui va tourner autour de
la connaissance tout ce qui va tourner
autour de d'apprendre et c'est important
de se dire dans ma vie actuelle futur
comment je peux régulièrement
m'alimenter pour ne pas être figé pour
ne pas être ses pieds programme de
dessécher
le troisième geste c'est un geste
important ce geste de la taille alors
les agrumes et en particulier les
citronniers en une force d'énergie
énorme si vous voyez un citron c'est
magnifique c'est très coloré et du coup
le site web un petit pouce il pousse
énormément et donc il faut le tailler
que c'est tania plus tôt au printemps et
à l'été
et quand je taille je vais en fait
couper des branches qui pourraient être
des fruits mais dans l'idée de
concentrer l'énergie de la plante donc
face à des fruits supérieur mais aussi
daniel lui donner une forme alors pour
nous cela revient nous poser la question
2 mais à quoi je qu'est-ce que je taille
dans ma vie aujourd'hui nous sommes
indues société du tro tro de mails trop
d'activités trop de travail trop de
charges et moi je vois des gens proche
de l'épuisement dans l'entreprise
pourquoi dire que j'en vois des gens qui
sont complètement épuisés certains le
savent certains ne savent pas donc
tailler régulièrement dans sa vie c'est
important renoncer accepté de dire ça
cheuveux plus alors serait sur le point
de jolis fruits ya tellement de choses
qu'on peut faire dans la vie on ne doit
pas assez d'une mais à un moment donné
c'est aussi accepter de renoncer alors
je peux taille et parce qu'à un moment
donné je trouve qu anna trop je peux
taille et aussi pour donner une
formation un projet d'opa taille est
trop tôt un agrume c'est à dire mais je
vais laisser un peu se disperser et puis
après je taille haies taillées et
renoncer mais c'est aussi apprendre à
s'alléger
c'est aussi apprendre à concentrer son
énergie dans la vie
le geste
suivant c'est le rempotage un agrume qui
pousse en fait il fait des racines y
pousser les racines il pousse les pots
et donc du coup les racines en fait à ce
mélange à s'entremêlent et en réalité il
prend moins de fertilisation moins
d'engrais du coup il se met à stagner
donc la question du rempotage se pose
rempotez s'est passé d'impôts un autre
il faut choisir le pot je le prends trop
petit ça sert à rien si je le prends
trop grand jeu risque de perdre la
plante c'est à dire qu'elle va mettre
beaucoup de temps à s'adapter
le rempotage de porno c'est tous les
changements et tout ce qui va faire
comment donner je change de lieu de vie
se changent de ville
je change de poste je change
d'entreprise quand je rends potes c'est
vraiment important de laisser du temps
de faire en sorte que je puisse créer
mes nouvelles racines
sinon moment donné je vais pas avoir
l'ancrage de suffisant pour avoir des
jolis fruits alors moi je vois
d'entreprise des gens qui quand ils
changent d'entreprise
ils sont à fond parce qu'ils sont dans
une nouvelle entreprise il faut qu'ils
prouvent
mais en fait ce qu'ils oublient et ça
les agrumes nous le rappelle ce que
quand je rampe automne agrumes et b
d'abord il fait ses racines avant de
faire les fruits
le geste suivant alors il est paradoxal
parce que c'est un nom geste suis là
c'est que j'ai fait beaucoup
j'ai choisi le déroger taille et j'ai
alimenté sciemment donné il faut que
j'arrête de faire quoi que ce soit il
faut que j'arrête parce que mais il faut
que la grume pouces j'ai beaucoup agi il
faut qu'ils acceptent de ne plus agir
alors ne plus agir attention ça veut pas
dire j'arrête de faire quoi que ce soit
c'est je suis l'aj auxerre je contemple
je me repose et accessoirement et puis
abandonnée si je vois que des consignes
et je peux traiter si je vois que ça
manque d'eau je rajoute de l'eau c'est
pas ne rien faire c'est abandonner et sa
peau non c'est pas simple cette idée là
c'est à dire que nous sommes dans une
société en faisant beaucoup beaucoup de
choses tout le temps on est un peu dans
une société il y aurait la croyance et
en particulier dans les entreprises que
si je veux je peux tout est question de
moyens ou de volonté
si je veux je mette plus de moyens plus
de gens puissent de personnes un peu
comme si on disait finalement maintien
de la prime pour le stimuler je vais
tirer la fleur et vous savez quoi ça
fait pas venir le fruit pour autant
aucun moment donné c'est être là présent
accepté aussi d'observer accepter aussi
d'être en situation de laisser la nature
faire et là tout ce qui est si je veux
je peux banon il manque une équation
c'est l'énergie extérieur c'est la
nature c'est le temps en particulier
il ya tellement de gens pressés aux
journées en tout cas pour voir des
agrumes me falloir du temps le suivant
alors ça c'est vraiment un moment joyeux
joyeux heureux un moment de grâce à
c'est le moment de la récolte je peux
vous dire quand vous récoltez des fruits
de ses couleurs là c'est un vrai plaisir
et surtout qu'en plus il se récolte
plutôt en hiver ce qui est chouette
parce qu'un hiver ça fait de la couleur
ça fait des vitamines comme c'est bon
pour les vitamines et s'ils se réjouir
parce que si je récolte c'est que j'ai
fait ce qu'il fallait
la nature a aussi fait la grume celui
qui a fait tout seul en réalité mais je
me réjouis parce qu'en fait ça s'est pas
fait sans rien il ya eu un peut-être
surtout quand les agrumes sont rampeau
c'est se réjouir quand j'ai qu'une
clémentine je peux vous dire que quand
vous allez qu'une imprimante ignore
c'est tout vous l'accueillez
celle-là vous la mangez quartier par
quartier vous la savez c'est aussi se
réjouir quand j'en ai trois kilos mais
je ne donnais un peu partout que j'en ai
fait des confitures j'en ai fait des
vins de fruits qu'à la fin j'en ai
ras-le-bol des agrumes basse et
apprennent aussi à certains joueurs
éreintés du trot et pour nous mais pour
moi c'est tout ce qui va toucher 1
est ce que je sais me réjouir de ce que
j'ai dans la vie des petits plaisirs des
petites joies de tout ce que je vais
vivre au jour le jour qui peut avoir du
sens qui peut me réjouis éléphants se
réjouit pas de france nous nous
réjouissons pour les autres et ils s'en
réjouissent pas surprenant c'est aussi
se réjouir et de se reconnaître le fait
qu'à un moment donné si je peut récolter
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il ya plein
de choses que j'ai fait avant s'il se
réjouit aussi parce que je suis en vie
et que je peux récoltés parce que aussi
des gens aujourd'hui qu'ils sont plus là
pour récolter donc la récolte ça doit
rester un moment joyeux
ça doit rester un moment plaisant alors
finalement avec les agrumes qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent les agréments de
termes odeur de sagesse ils nous disent
en fait deux choses
ils ne disent un agrume c'est simple ça
besoin d'un sol ça besoin de soleil
sable aux wendo sa besoin d'engrais avec
ça ça fait les choses superbes des
bouffes quid de belles couleurs des
belles formes des belles saveurs mais
nous c'est pareil nous avec peu de
choses des choses simples mais nous
pouvons faire des belles choses et pour
la plupart vous en fait de belles choses
mais ça veut dire aussi quoi ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut que j'apprenne à
revenir dans le geste à revenir dans la
conscience à revenir dès fois dans la
répétition à revenir dans le fait qu au
jour le jour je vais faire ce qu'il faut
peut-être pour avoir de la récolte
je vois beaucoup de gens qui en fait
pour évaluer leur journée leur semaine
leur temps sur qu'est-ce que je récolte
il pourrait mesurer leur activité leur
vie à la lumière de ce qui s'y de ce
qu'il récolte
parce que je vous propose de commencer à
mesurer vous via la lumière de ce que
vous semez à la lumière de tous les
petits gestes que vous faites qui vont
faire que petit à petit ça la semaine
un peu comme quand une personne est une
entreprise que tout est fait finalement
par section est fait
les produits sont là tout est là et puis
à un moment donné ça n'arrive pas c'est
de dire je me réjouis d'avoir semé
parce qu'un jour je devrais récoltés
alors finalement pour terminer j'avais
envie de revenir cette mission de perdre
parce que le pépin on peut le voir de
différentes façons le pépin pour un être
humain il peut être tragique et combien
je vois moi de gens autour de moi dans
mon environnement professionnel qui
attendent le gros pépin l'accident le
deuil la maladie pour se mettre à
changer des choses à changer leur agenda
à changer leur heure pour revenir à la
maison a changé leur équilibre de vie a
changé leur alimentation et j'ai envie
de vous dire n'attendez pas se plaint
parce que je suis là honnêtement quand
ils arrivent c'est pas top
moi j'ai peut-être eu la sagesse la
sagesse de tomber sur un pépin et de me
dire derrière sur le pen qui était à la
fois embêtant mais pas trop grave il ya
peut-être quelque chose à apprendre
j'ai appris et puis le pépin je peux
aussi le voir d'une autre façon c'est
comme des pinces une graine une graine
que je peut semer une graine qu'il a une
promesse à la promesse donne demain peu
différent peut-être eu avec une vie plus
harmonieuse plus heureuse plus allégée
suivre ce que vous voulez mais en tout
cas de me dire que je suis pas obligé
d'attendre le gros pépin pour dire que
dans le ppri il ya des choses que je
peux se met que je peut planter et moi
pour terminer j'ai envie de vous dire
demain matin quelle est la petite graine
le petit pépin que vous aller semer vous
faites vous faire que votre vie soit
plus heureuse
merci
[Applaudissements]